round for the day um there's a reception
right after uh
this session at um
4 30
just out i believe my guess is that it's
just going to be literally behind this
wall
i hope you will be able to join and then
with that
over to you spencer for the last round
thanks okay
so
at the end of
the last session
we had introduced the augmented
graph construction which is used to
reason
about
which is a device for
proving
rules in the due calculus because we can
manipulate
additional independences involving
these intervention variables correspond
to uh statements about when you can
ignore observations or actions or switch
between observations or actions yes
sorry one
question as a reminder what graph is the
g x z
um
yeah so
the question is what is
this graph here g with an x bar over and
a z power under it so i get to define z
bar under it so
the answer is
x bar is you remove all the edges from
parents of x into x z bar as you move
all the edges from children of
z uh from z to children of z
um
and yeah so the next thing we're gonna
do is prove rule 2 which
tells us when we can
replace an action with an observation
yes
i'm sort of losing
a different picture
why do we want to do these uh
transformations or what what's the
purpose of
um the purpose is
uh well
we're gonna
state and not show but uh state that
and i can direct you to the paper in
which it's shown that
these rules are sufficient for
uh
determining identifiability
of
interventional distributions from
observable distributions okay so
if it's possible to identify an
interventional distribution then you can
do it by applying
these rules in some order
um it won't necessarily be easy to do it
and i wouldn't recommend trying to do it
necessarily by hand if you have a
complicated example but it can be done
um
and
these are sort of the fundamental
building blocks of manipulating and
interventional distributions in
particular you're eliminating things you
don't want and getting them into a nicer
form
[Music]
yeah okay so
let me
tell you the statement of
before we prove rule two which will turn
out to be easy to prove once we have
this lama we're going to prove this
lemma
and so what what does this say this
relates
d separation in the original graph
sort of the original graph that is
the graph where we've
intervened on x and removed all the
edges into x and where we've removed
edges out of z and you'll see why that's
relevant
later but uh
we're going to relate um d separations
in this graph h
to d separations in the augmented graph
with respect to eight with respect to z
uh where
we're now looking at these separations
between this uh intervention variable
for z and y
right and so
uh you can see hopefully why
this d separation might be useful right
saying that
uh
why is d separated from this
intervention variable for z
given
x c and w
is exactly what you think it is it's
saying that
once i've observed x z and w
telling me whether or not z was obtained
via an intervention
uh doesn't give me additional
information about why and so that's
exactly what this statement says here
right once i've conditioned on
uh or once i've
it's almost
what this statement says uh right once
it's saying that i can
switch between doing z and observing z
without any
change in the resulting distribution on
y
so
our first task is to prove this lemma
which is not too bad
um
so how do we go about doing this um
so
we are going to
prove each direction
separately and we're going to do the
same sort of reasoning that we've done
before which is take active trails
in uh witnessing deconnection here turn
them into active trails witnessing the
connection here and vice versa
so
let's say we have an active trail t
in
h
between
some x star
some y star
uh
given
x and w
and we now want to find an active trail
in this augmented graph
between
z hat and y
um so
sorry this should be
z
star so by
z star i just mean some arbitrary
element of z
um
okay so
the first thing to observe is
this active trail
can't pass through
any
z uh vertices because
right we're working in this graph h
where we've removed all the edges out of
z vertices
um and so
the only way to pass through any of the
other z vertices is to use it as a
collider
but
we're not conditioning on z here
so this would deactivate the trail and
it has no descendants
that we could be
conditioning on to make this part active
so it would immediately deactivate the
trail so this can't happen
so the only z vertex that can appear in
this trail
is z star
which means that we can modify the trail
by just
adding to it the edge
from
z
star
hat
to z star
and now we know that the the subsequent
edge
that uh occurs in the trail t
uh must have been an edge into z star
because again there are no edges out of
z star in this graph h so
the trail starts off so our new modified
trail is going to start off with a
collider that looks like this
and
we are interested in a conditional
independent statement with respect to
uh where we can we're conditioning on z
in this augmented graph
so
this collider is in fact active when we
condition on z
and since there are no other occurrences
of z vertices elsewhere
in this trail um we immediately get that
everywhere else in the trail remains
active
since we're not conditioning on anything
in the trail
um
and
we're not removing edges when we go to
this augment augmented graph so we
immediately conclude that this trail
where we've just added this one edge is
active
in the augmented graph
so
uh
d connection in h
implies d connection here
now we need to do the other direction
um
okay so
uh for the other direction we're going
to let t be an active trail in
this augmented graph
uh between
z hat star
and y star and we're now going to add to
our conditioning set z
um
okay
so let's look at what the start of this
trail looks like um it's going to have
to have an edge
uh from z hat star to z star
because that's the only edge
uh incident to z hat star
and
it ends at some y star
and first observation is
well
so another observation is
not only does this have to be the first
edge but the next edge has to be
in this direction because again there
are no edges leaving z star
um so we start off with this collider
that is made active by conditioning on z
star
so now i want to consider
the collider on this trail
nearest to y star
that contains
a
descendant
in the conditioning set
that is
reachable
uh
this frame sorry that has a directed
path
to a descendant in z
that doesn't pass through an x or w
vertex
so that's a mouthful so
what i want to consider is the collider
on this trail nearest to y star
um
satisfying the additional criterion that
it has a descendant in z
that doesn't get reached by going
through an x or w vertex
so why must any such colliders exist
because this right here is an example of
one
there may not be any others this may be
the only one
but
this is a collider
where
the collider contains a descendant in z
namely
the vertex itself
that is reachable without going through
any x or w vertices because it has a
path of length zero
um
so let's find the one closest to y star
um
and now let
z of j
or z sub j be
the vertex in z that is
reachable via the path i described
from c
um
and now we're gonna look at a new trail
um
that we get by concatenating
this part of
uh or this path here to this trail
here um
okay so first observation
is there are no z hat vertices along
this trail
because
z hat vertices have degree one
and everything along here has degree two
um or at least degree two
uh moreover and so
since z hat
uh is the only place where
h differs from this augmented graph
uh we know that all these edges exist in
the non-augmented sorry in in h without
the augmentations
uh
moreover
there are no other z vertices along this
trail
than zj because
uh
if they were they would have to be in
colliders because there are no edges
going out of z vertices in this graph
and uh we've already picked
this to be the furthest right collider
uh that has a z vertex as a descendant
and um
uh
and if there were any other
collider with the z vertex as a
descendant um
that would contradict our choice of c
um
and then finally this segment is active
because it contains no x or w vertices
and it's just a chain
and uh
this segment is active in h because it
uh was active in the augmented graph and
um
we've and it contains no colliders
um
uh
sorry because it contains no z vertices
um
and
uh and
sorry it contains no colliders that are
made active by only z vertices
and so when we go from conditioning on x
z and w to just conditioning on x and w
we're not going to accidentally
deactivate any of the colliders here
because all of these are made active by
something other
than a z vertex if it was made active by
z vertex that would contradict this
being the furthest right
collider made active only by z or made
active by z vertex before x are done um
okay
that was kind of a mouthful but the
punch line is
d separations here
or these d separations happen if and
only if we have this sort of
deseparation
um
the reason for going to this detail is
that uh
this i find to be a much more intuitive
condition
than this reasoning about
uh these augmented graphs i think is
much simpler than trying to understand
what
is going on here like
well anyway
it's at least
a little bit easier i think not that
either one is particularly intuitive um
anyway so now that we've established
this we'll prove
that the rule follows from dislema
okay so again we're going to let h be
this graph
where we've
removed the parents of x and the
children of z
and now
we're going to assume that this holds
and now use that this holds
so
we now know that
z hat is independent of y
given x
z
and w
in
this augmentation
of h
with respect to z i claim that this also
um means that
z hat
is independent
of y
given
x
z and w
in
the augmentation only with respect or
sorry in the augmentation with respect
to z
of the graph where we haven't removed
the children
of
z right so i'm replacing h here with the
augmentation
of the graph where we haven't removed
the children out of z
and the reason for this is
once we're conditioning on z
um
there's no way to get
uh
so there are two types of paths
from
z hat
uh right there are z hat paths
that go into z
and then continue down
and these are blocked by conditioning on
z
and then this condition establishes
that we've blocked the other paths that
are
that use z as a collider
so
once we know that
these are blocked
uh we also get to conclude the stronger
thing that
um
these pads are blocked in the graph
where we haven't removed all these
children
of z
and now
we
just use this d separation so we write
well
[Music]
so um
i claim that replacing the do here with
an x is equivalent if we're already
working in the interventional
distribution
uh so once i've intervened on x then i
can condition on x
i don't really want to prove this or
spell it out but
my word for it uh
so
this first manipulation i've just
replaced the do here with conditioning
but i'm still working in an
interventional distribution so this
isn't a substantive
change um
uh
but now i'm going to
replace this with an interventional
graph expression
so here i've now switched to working in
the interventional the augmented model
and um
doing z in the original model is the
same thing as
observing that this augmented variable
has the value z
and then observing the z has the value z
um
the
distribution um
uh
okay
uh and then
now i'm gonna now i have an expression
with a y x z hat z and w
and
um i want to
get rid of the z hat to get something
back in the world without intervention
variables
and so i'm going to use exactly
this d separation
um or sorry not exactly this d
separation i'm going to use this d
separation right because the graph i'm
working in is the augment is the
the graph where i've intervened on x
um
and
uh sorry
so i skipped a step which is
if
z hat's conditionally independent from y
given everything else
then it's then i haven't changed
anything when i set z hat equal to
epsilon
at which point i now am back in the
world where i'm where z hat or where z
acts freely uh
and this is a genuine unforced
observation of
z
and now
um
uh
this distribution is the same thing as
sorry that's
visible
so
um
yeah so the d separation was needed
to reason about
or to to argue that
uh
setting z hat to z
uh is indistinguishable from
setting z hat to epsilon
uh as long as i'm already observing the
value of z
at which point um when i'm in the world
where z hat's equal to epsilon that just
is the original
uh causal model where i haven't
uh that's a statement that i can say
about the original causal model where i
don't even have these intervention
variables
um
is that uh
uh yes do you mean p hat for the second
last line and third last line
yeah so sorry what i
previously i i
wrote p-hat for this distribution and
when i in the model where i've added
augmented variables
um
i so i do mean p hat though i also think
as long as
it's
as long as it's clear that whenever i
have an interventional or whenever i
have an intervention variable i'm not
i've like i'm working in the model where
i've added those
i don't think it's necessary to
like there's only one logical
p
in the world
i should add a hat i'm gonna be lazy and
not add hats everywhere
and just freely manipulate these
quantities uh
it should be clear from context which
world i'm working in at what time
um
other there was another question
okay um
so that is
rule
two
um
let's move on to rule three which is
maybe the most powerful
in the following sense uh
so what is rule 3 it says
that
it characterizes when you can not only
replace
an action with an observation
as in the previous one but when you can
drop an action entirely right so
here i have
y given do x do z and w
and
here
i've removed the doozy
entirely
um
and
this uh
yeah
it's
it has a very weird formulation
that uh often throws people
um
because
it requires de-separation in this mirror
graph where i
not only remove parents and
eggs but i also remove parents of a
subset of the z vertices
uh this apostrophe shouldn't be there
ignore that
uh namely zw which is the set of z
vertices
that are not ancestors of w
in the graph where i've already
intervened on x
so first of all to parse this i would
recommend
just
ignoring the du x component everywhere
because it's constant
um
and just thinking
uh
this is saying that
um
i can drop the action due z
if z is d separated from our effect
in the world where i've
removed all the parents of z
uh
vertices that are not ancestors of men
it's still not i still don't have a
great intuition for it but uh
yeah
um
okay so
the
meat uh the
claim
um
or the meat of the
theorem is going to be
islama which
is
uh also not super intuitive to state
but um
hopefully gives a little bit more
intuition so
uh it says that if i have a trail that's
active
in
the augmented
graph
um
post intervention on x but where i've
done augmentations with z
um
and this trail only uses edges
from
[Music]
this graph
then it's also active
in this graph
and the the reason this is going to be
useful is
uh
we can
we'll show that
we'll see why this is useful after we've
proven it but uh let's just prove it um
okay so
we need to give more concise names for
these graphs
so g1 is going to be
the augmented graph
where we've done the intervention on x
and we've augmented with respect to z
g2 is going to be
this graph where we've cut in addition
to z all the edges into
the z vertices that are not ancestors of
w
and let t
be a trail
that's active
given x and w and that uses edges in g2
only
okay
so
the uh
issue here is that
i might use only edges from this graph
but
the other edges that have been cut
might somehow still deactivate
my trail um and so the claim is going to
be that as long as the trail is active
in g1 and uses only the edges that are
present here the other edges you don't
have to worry about
um
so
why is this um well first of all
um
all the orientations of edges in g1 and
g2 are the same
and
the set of conditioning variables is the
same so all non-collider triples
anytime you have
v1
to v2 to v3 and it's not a collider
um
or it's a collider where the conditioned
descendant is an x or w you're fine
that'll stay active in g2
because you haven't changed anything in
g2 and the conditioning sets the same
and if you're only and if your
uh collider is made active by x or w
it's still going to be active because
you haven't caught any of those edges
um
so the only remaining case is a collider
triple where
collider triple where
there exists a w
um
as a descendant
um
sorry let me back up a second so my
claim was if this is anything other than
a collider or a collider where v2 itself
is an x or w you're fine the only case
you have to worry about is
a collider where you have some
descendant in w
because that's uh
the only situation in which cutting an
edge here could break this and prevent
this from being active
and um
right x has no parents in either of this
graph or this graph so x is not the
reason that this is active in either
case
um
and
okay
so
the next observation is that
um
so let's actually just give a name to
this we'll call it w star uh and so this
is going to be a descendant
of
in g1
of v2
that is in w
um
so now our claim is that this path is
also present in
g1
and the reason is that no z
hat uh
sorry uh
no z vertex can be on this path because
we've only cut
uh z vertices that aren't ancestors of w
that's it
uh
so this path remains
and we conclude that it's also active in
this other graph
so that was a handful but
i've established this lemma and now
we're going to show
that
we can always find uh
we're now going to show that um
a d separation that will hopefully be
more intuitive but uh
this was an unfortunate but necessary uh
lemma
so
you want to now use this lemma to prove
this result
um
so we're going to assume that we have
y d separated or
sorry uh
we're gonna now show that um
that
this assumption here
gives us
that
z
hat
is
d separated from y
given x and w
in h
where h
is
the augmented graph
uh with respect to z
uh sorry it's the augmented graph where
we've intervened on x
and then added the intervention
variables for
z um
uh
so actually you know i'm looking at the
time
i think this would be less illuminating
than
uh talking about the id algorithm so
all i want to say is that
what we're going to end up showing
is that this condition
implies
this separation
and this separation is actually
something that is sort of comprehensible
right z hat being d separated from y
given x and w means that doing an
intervention
is
uh gives you no information about why
once you've already observed x and w
in the graph where you've already
observed where you've already intervened
on x and this is exactly
what
you can see how if you were able to show
this that would immediately imply this
that you can drop an intervention on z
so the bulk of the work in proving this
is just establishing that this condition
is actually sufficient
to get this d separation
um
but again i'm not sure how illuminating
will be
so i'm going to move on uh for the sake
of time
um
yeah
anyway so
we've sort of proven the three uh
rules of the due calculus
um which now leads us to the schwitzer
pearl id algorithm which again we're not
have time to say all that much about
um
but
let me
restate the context for this so the
question is what causal effects
can be determined from observed
variables only
um
and
that's character
we use the notion of identifiability to
uh
to uh frame this more precisely and so
we'll say that the causal effect of an
intervention do x on a set of variables
y
is identifiable from
uh
p in a dag g if
um
it's uniquely computable
from the observed variables
in any causal model that induces
the graph
so you have only access to
the distribution over observed variables
and
a dag which
induces or which comes from
uh
a causal model
with those observed variables and this
dag
uh
sorry there should be a
um
in a
dag with bi-directed edges
and uh
the question is can you compute
uh the interventional distribution from
the observed variables and the graph
um
and so the schmitzer pearl algorithm
which again is not the only
identification algorithm
in particular there was a contemporaries
contemporaneous result by huang and
voltorta
that was essentially the same as this so
the algorithm looked very different and
there have been a lot of different
algorithm since then
they have an algorithm
id
which will do one of two things
if
the interventional distribution
for some given
target target variables uh to intervene
on and effect variables to uh look at
if that's identifiable it will return an
expression for
the uh
of y when you intervene on x and if it's
not identifiable
it will return a witness to
non-identifiability so a concrete proof
that it's not identifiable in a form to
be described in a minute
um so sorry just to be clear the input
here
is
the graph and
x and y the description of the subsets
and then you get a symbolic expression
that you could then evaluate given
your data
uh or given your distribution of repeat
over the observables uh to come up with
a concrete answer
um
yes
this requires
the distribution
yes we saw it already in the example
before
actually just to make one comment i
think what you've got there it doesn't
but the previous what you had on
previous slide did
because i think the expression is
holds
okay
uh
let me
think about this offline
to figure out exactly what i mean to say
but
um and
every line of the algorithm is going to
turn out to be an application of the
rule of a rule from the two calculus i'm
not going to have time to
describe it i'll basically just going to
flash the algorithm on the screen
convince you that it's not totally
incomprehensible
and then talk about what it finds when
you
when it fails when things are not
identifiable because i think that's
uh interesting in its own right and um
yeah i think it's worth thinking
so
what does this algorithm do it takes in
your
well the way it's written it takes in
some assignment to y some assignment x
your observed distribution and your
graph
and
it just recursively
uh
does
one of a couple different things
so if
you somehow are in a case where you're
no longer intervening on anything
well then it's just uh the marginal
distribution on
um
the
uh on on y that you get by marginalizing
out everything not in y
um
if
your vertex set contains stuff that are
not in the ancestors of y
then you just
recurse where you've restricted things
to just the ancestors of y
if um
uh
you have vertices w that are
not an x and they're not in the
ancestors of y uh
when
you look at the set of vertices
that are not an x and not in the
ancestors of y when you've done the
intervention
and if this set
is not zero then
you have to augment the
set of intervention variables to include
uh these and this is i think maybe the
most mysterious step because somehow
you're getting some assignment for w
that uh
you didn't provide to the algorithm
and it turns out it will later not
matter
uh and that the resulting quantity will
be independent of w
which uh
but it's nevertheless needed for the
algorithm
um
so subsequent steps
rely on this decomposition into c
components which i'll describe in a
minute
and uh
the details again are
beyond
the scope of the next
20 minutes
but it's hopefully not
as scary as it was a minute ago
so let me
go through two examples
that illustrate what it does
so
let's look at the following
uh graph
for this graph um and and the following
question like can we identify the effect
of
x on y1 and y2
and then
as a subsequent question can we do the
same thing
where we've added an edge from w1 to w2
um so it turns out the in the former
case the answer is
yes this is identifiable
and uh we get back the following not
super terrible expression
um which i
don't
have
time to drive and i'm not sure i could
drive it without uh spending
a lot of time uh
if i were trying to do it by hand um
but let me just introduce to you some of
the tools that are needed to be able to
run this algorithm so the most important
concept i think that
is used in this algorithm is the notion
of a c component and so this is a
um
so sorry just to
define some terms a semi-markovian graph
is a is a dag with the addition of
bi-directed edges
um
and so a c component here is
some uh
is a connected component in
with respect to bi-directed edges
so
if this is my graph
i have
two c components i have one it consists
of uh sorry three c components one that
consists of
these
vertices
another one that's just a singleton
and another one that's this singleton
and uh it turns out all the difficulty
comes when you have
uh look you can decompose
uh your identification problem into
a problem
for each c component
separately um
right so step four
says
when you remove x does that break the if
it breaks the graph into multiple c
components
then
you can
solve the problem independently on each
of the c components
and then combine those in the
appropriate way
and
yes we have these bi-directed edges when
we have
one unobserved variable pointing to
two
but what do we do if we have
one unobserved that points to three or
four do we have like a notion of a of a
hyper edge here or do we just say
you know i'm just going to take
and put in all you know dashed pairs
amongst these these these three uh so
we're going to just put in all dash
pairs and the claim is that by doing
that
we have enough information to decide if
the problem is identifiable or not and
uh
that all the conditional independence
relationships between observed variables
that are needed to compute
uh
the expression if we run
the id algorithm and it is identifiable
that all those conditional independence
relationships are
uh
described by putting in all these pairs
and so that's sufficient even though
it's not uh
you're not accurately representing the
way that the these hidden variables talk
to things
it's sufficient to be able to solve the
question to use this uh pairwise
representation
um
okay so
yeah can you go to the example
um i was just wondering like uh
so in this graph though like the effect
of x on y2 seems a little bit cryptic to
me like the graph suggested
um
like from x there's no forward direction
yeah
um i was just wondering i was just
wondering because it kind of struck me
as as a kind of
but like x and y one that i see that
perfect makes perfect sense but yeah i
agree it's a kind of weird uh example
it's actually
from uh
the paper in which
this the id algorithm is introduced and
it describes a realistic sounding
setup that leads to this graph as to why
you'd be interested in looking at the
effect of x on y2 when it doesn't seem
like it would have
uh any obvious
effect given that it or
uh
there's a path through white one
um
so first of all the formula you can see
you can move the summation over w2 and
it doesn't as you observed it really
doesn't matter it kind of factors out
but i think the reason it's given the
example is because it's going to show
non-identifiability when you get the
extra edge that was in red oh i see and
that's kind of so it's kind of setting
up like you're setting up the counter i
see okay yeah and i think the
non-identifiability is more surprising
given that y2 doesn't seem that
you know having
this additional edge
uh
given x2 or
y2 still is not on a direct causal path
it's more surprising that if you're
looking for the effect with y2 somehow
things go wrong
um just just just just add one other
little comment here which is that if you
identify the effect of
x on y1 and y2 then that also means you
know the conditional effect of x on y1
given
y2 in this example so that's that's why
y2 is not totally irrelevant here
because we're identifying a joint
distribution
yeah so
this algorithm is going to use a
decomposition of your graph into c
components so
this sort of decomposition where
each
component is a
has a spanning tree of just bi-directed
edges
and
the counter example object is going to
involve a sea forest which is
an even more elaborate thing so what is
a c forest it's a
c component that is also
a forest with respect to visible edges
um
and
why rooted sea forest is one
it means that it's a forest where the
roots of the forest are in the set y so
if y
was
so this was y1
this
uh was uh
this is y2 and i had a bi-directed edge
here
now i have two
uh
c components only
um
uh
sorry so let me add
one more bi-directed edge
so now i have one c component
and
a graph that on the visible vertices
is a
forest with roots at y1 and y2
so this is a messy picture but
this is a y rooted c forest
uh
we'll see why this is relevant in a
second
so the obstruction to identifiability is
this object called a hedge
which
involves
c4s as follows so if i want to identify
the effect of x on y
then
um
if i can find a hedge
with respect
or if i can find a hedge with respect to
x and y
then i have a proof that it's not
identifiable
and what a hedge consists of
two
r rooted c forests
such that
the smaller one doesn't contain any
vertex from x
and the larger one does contain a vertex
from f from from
x so here f prime is a small forest
f is a large forest
f prime does not contain anything in x
f does contain something in x
and f is obtained by adding stuff
to f prime
and the root of this of these uh
c forests
the roots the set of roots have to be
ancestors of y
so
the picture is something the abstract
picture is something like this and i'll
always i'll then illustrate it with a
concrete example which will hopefully
give you a flavor
for why or a little bit of a taste of
why this is uh
going to give it an
identifiability um so you have
your set y
so you have this f
prime
which is some sort of
uh
confounded component
c component
with roots at the y
vertices or ancestors of y that's also
okay um
uh but all of these are confounded
together
and
so this is your f prime
and then you
your f is obtained by
taking this
forest and adding
some more edges
that somehow preserve the confounding
and so you get one bigger
c component
and now here you have to have an x
vertex
so this is still i think very mysterious
let me illustrate with an example
uh so this is not the most interesting
example because
it's not really that surprising that the
effect of x on y
is not identifiable in this graph
because there are a lot of bi-directed
edges floating around everywhere
nevertheless you can
hopefully see a little bit of what this
looks like so here
what is the hedge
that proves that x the effect of x and y
cannot be identified well it's going the
smaller forest is just going to be the
vertex y so this is trivial
and the larger one is going to be
all four of these vertices so first
thing to note is this a
y rooted c forest
or an r rooted c for us where r is some
ancestor y yes so
we have
a root here
at uh
y
and a single
tree
um
and then
the bi-directed edges in red
uh
are a spanning tree on that same set of
vertices
so how does this show
non-identifiability so first i'm going
to expand out the by bi-directed edges
to include
uh
the to explicitly show the hidden
variables
i'm going to drop this extra bi-directed
edge
and now i'm going to describe two models
that generate the same observable
statistics that nevertheless
produce different
results for the causal effect and that
is a proof that it's not identifiable
so what are the two models so i need to
specify
how you the u variables are distributed
and then i need to give functions
computing all the other variables uh
based on their parents and uh
based on their parents yeah
the way that you are looking for to show
no identification it seems to me that
you can use the same type of
so look for all the potential
distribution that conversion
and then get some kind of
afformativeness from them right so it's
not clear to me why you want to answer
the question in the very time
yeah so the question was
like why are why are we interested in
the kind of dichotomy between being
identifiable and getting a single answer
or
like uh
we give up and say there's nothing at
all we can do and the answer is often
we're not interested and often there are
more precise things we can say but this
is like the totally non-parametric no
assumptions at all
setting
and it's at the very least
i mean well you can imagine a setting in
which you have no assumptions that allow
you to
say anything
more
concrete and
uh it's a good starting point
and yeah
i think it's often interesting to
consider
restricted settings or to consider you
know
bounds that you can get even in the
absence of identifiability um
yeah and and this counter example will
in fact like be
uh
bad in the sense that it
is a very contrived example where
things are
like it's easy to make assumptions that
would break this counter example
um and you'll see that right now
so what is this a counter example so i'm
writing two models here
um
that generate the same induced graph
and they're almost the same
the only difference is how y is
determined
so again the well not again for the
first time so the u variables each of
them are set uniformly either to zero or
one
and then
every other variable every other
variable in model one at least is set to
be the parity
uh
of
all of its parents
and so by the parity i mean the sum
mod 2.
so if u 4 is 1 u 3 is 1 and u 1 0 then z
is going to take 1 plus 1 plus 0 is 2
mod 2 is 0.
uh and then x is gonna take it on value
equal to z
plus u one mod two and so if u one is
zero and z is zero then x is gonna be
zero as well
so that's how we generate
the data um
and
m2 is going to be the exact same thing
with the one difference that y
is just set to the constant zero
so the first claim is that the
probability that we see
y
equals zero in model one
is one
so the observable statistics on all the
other variables clearly are going to be
the same
in both models because they're set
according to the same
equations
and so the only thing we have to do to
verify that these two models generate
the same observables is verify that
y is always equal to zero in the obs in
the observational distribution in model
one
so why is that well
let's look at the expression we use to
compute y
so
i'm just going to
trace back using all these equations
and expanding each thing out one at a
time so y is w plus u4 but w is x plus
u3
uh
sorry uh yeah x plus
u3
and then x is z plus u1 and then z is
u34 u3 plus u4 plus u1 and you'll see
that the expression here contains
every u
exactly twice
and so the parity mod 2
is going to be 0 or that the sum mod 2
is going to be 0.
so the observational distributions are
exactly the same
now why are the interventional
distributions different
well when we intervene on x
in
model one let's look at the resulting
graph
so we remove the z to x edge we remove
the u one to x edge
and we change the equations for x in
both models
and what happens to y well
y in model 2 stays
equal to 0
because it
the equation defining it hasn't changed
but in model 1
y
is now
set to w plus u4 which when we expand
back out
is equal to x plus u3 plus u4
and now no matter what value of x
we choose there's some probability that
u3 and u4 have the uh
have parodies they're
sorry there's some probability that this
expression is not equal to zero and so
the probability that y
is uh
is equal to one
uh in this model is greater than zero
and in particular
uh
since in model two it's still equal to
zero
we have different interventional
distributions despite having exactly the
same observational
distributions
um
so
this is a very contrived example there
are lots of ways we can modify it to
make it less contrived so we could
uh
make things positive by kind of just
adding
some independent uh
by having each variable basically
only half the time listen to its
predecessors and the other at the time
set its value independently we can do
things like that
as long as we have this
um
but the point is this is the kind of
minimal core example for this sort of
thing like we have
binary random variables and
we get that y is equal to one with
probability greater than zero here
but
equal to zero here and so we've
established unidentified
unidentifiability
and
whenever you have a hedge
right you have two forests
where
the smaller forest doesn't contain any x
vertices and the larger one does
and
the same model the this counter example
generalizes to any for any hedge
because
you do the exact same thing where
the only difference is you set
the equations in model 2
to be the constant zero where at the
boundary of the smaller forest so okay
i'm going way too fast to make this at
all clear
the point is
uh you can set it up so that
the target of your intervention has a
probability of
uh is
the target of your intervention in one
model
uh is just a constant and the target of
your intervention the other model is the
parity of a bunch of stuff and you can
set it up so the parodies all
coincide
are all
work together so that you get
a constant value in both observational
distributions but then when you turn to
interventions
you get a difference
um
and
just
finally
what does the non-identifiability proof
look like
for the earlier example
so in this case
the non-identifiability comes from
the following pair of forests so our
smaller forest is w1
w2 y2
y1 so it doesn't contain x and it is a
y rooted c forest right it contains this
vertex and then these two edges so it's
a forest and the roots for y and then
it's a single c component because
there's a bi-directed edge
uh between w and y two w w1 w2 and w1
and y1
and then the larger force we just just
comes by adding back in x and it's still
a c component because of this edge
and then
you can apply the same sort of
counter example to prove non-identity
identifiability and so here
it's important that we're looking at the
effect on y2 to get non-identifiability
right if we were just looking at
y1
then uh
this counter example wouldn't work uh
right we couldn't find some
uh i think it wouldn't work
because this equal need to go to w2
or y2 and that but then that wouldn't be
part of the foreign one yeah okay
yeah so what leonard just said right we
need a c component that goes through y
one
uh
and eventually through x as well and
there's no way to get that without going
around to this
stuff over here
um
yeah anyway okay i think i'm past my
time so that's pretty much all i wanted
to say
um
[Applause]
um what was the so the algorithm we went
through it kind of fast very nice at
this recursive step um
what is the running time of this
algorithm is this thing that like just
terminates a finite amount of time or
does it have
like a clean running time
is it is it um
i don't know when it's a little bit hard
to say because
it depends on whether you treat it
symbolically or numerically because
uh
the input
if it's if you think of the input as
just being a graph and not like a
concrete distribution you can get some
symbolic expression
in i think linear time but then
because the recursion recurses on
strictly smaller graphs and i think on
disjoint portions of the graph as far as
i can as far as i remember
so i think it's linear time symbolically
so the same question was asked on zoom
actually and ilya is on the zoom and so
he gave an answer that says it says it's
two parts really of uh answer to the
running time question one is do you look
at this algorithm just as answering the
question of identifiability versus
non-identifiability if that's just all
you're doing
and it's apparently no polynomial
if you are also asking about getting the
actual estimator for so when it's
identifiable you want to get the actual
estimator
it's much more complicated
when you say estimators here do you do
you mean
the expression itself or what do you
mean
to actually compute probability of y
with do x okay
but just to say if for that second
question the input size is quite
different
so for the identifiable question your
input is the graph of the set x and the
set y
for the second question you need the
distribution which is
exponentially larger suppose these are
binary variables
so then the the input is is
exponentially larger actually
except except it factorizes so it
depends a little right
there is a concise representation for it
after the fact
but as an input
there's a right but
but
statistically we take the input to be
data so
yes might be strong
supposed to
have well not necessarily but anyway
yeah
thomas do you want to go with your
question
yeah so i just had a comment which uh
which is just a notational comment and
it may be clear to everyone but it but
it was something which struck me about
the notation from this morning and from
the results of being presented this
afternoon so this so essentially that
the point is that may be obvious to
everyone but might not be is that the
notation p sub x
which you're also using to represent do
of x
that that is a function of a graph that
you are positing
and it's not just a function of the
distribution and so so in particular you
had the results this morning where you
said i could have two different graphs
that are markov equivalent
and those two if you're
if uh if two graphs markov equivalent
and a distribution that is markov or
compatible with one graph will be
compatible with the other graph
um and then this afternoon you had a
result that said well if i if i can
if a distribution is compatible with a
graph then the intervention distribution
p sub x will be compatible with the
graph g sub x
and uh because p sub x and d of x don't
aren't indexed by graphs somebody might
naively think that then okay well if g
and g star are markov equivalent
then p sub x
is the same from both of those graphs
and so i just think it's important to
stress here that those that's not the
case that whenever you talk about p sub
x there is a graph in the background and
the p sub x you get out from a markov
equivalent graph will be different even
for the same distribution that was just
a comment and maybe it's clear to
everyone but i wanted to emphasize that
because the notation kind of
didn't show that
that's all the questions i saw are there
any more in the room
let's thank spencer
[Applause]
section outside tomorrow we'll be
talking about causal discovery dan
lelinski will be doing the presentation
so today we saw a lot of results that
assumed knowledge of the graphs of
tomorrow the question will be how do we
get the graphic first
so back here at uh
i think it's 9 30 again so uh
enjoy the reception